Hey how's it going bros my name is PewDiePie
and today I'm joined *applause sound effect* with the very special
guest clap it up everyone foooor Edga-
Where the fuck did he go?
Hey, how's it going bros my name is Pewdiepie and welcome to the very
special guest
Edgar gOD DAMNIT! what the fuck-
(To be continued earrape)
*speaks in swedish* okay come on lie, lie,lie
Good Edgar! Well done! You're so good Edgar!
Edgar: Shut the fuck up Felix.
Now let's begin today's video!
There is a reason I have Edgar as a respected guest here today
because today's theme is...
Respect. Thank you Markiplier. Respect. Not
just any form of respect but respect
wahmen. It's become a meme on the internet
to respect women. Usually it looks like
this: we have a subject. We have an item
or an action, and then we have a wahman
and it's usually pretty ho-rrible to
see respecting wahmen is no joke. (Laughing) it is no
joke to joke about! That cat needs those
pills. And so does women need respect.
Edgar is still a teenager. I need to
teach him how to properly respect women
and not like all these stupid memes!
Are you- are you paying attention Edgar?!
Hell yes! Cool!
Well let's do. This let's begin with
WikiHow! How to treat a woman. Being
number one being a good communicator.
Well if you have to whisper
then I doubt you're a good communicator.
What the fuck are you saying?
I bet he's saying something sexist. Be a
good listener. Ask her how she's feeling.
Fight fair.
But most of all show respect. This is me
when I respect wahmen. If you ever see me
do this that means I am currently
respecting women. I don't know about you guys but
i got a lot of respect for women.
One day Edgar, my son you will be able
to respect women just as well as I do.
Are you listening? (Scream) Alright he's paying
close attention. (Laughs) I love this thing...
Behave like a gentleman. Treat her fairly.
Don't open doors, this just shows you
think she's weak. (claps and laughs) RESPECT WOMEN! You don't
open the doors for the wahmen! that just
makes her think she's weak. You gotta let
her open her own doors so she knows she
is strong enough to open that door
herself. If there's a man- you open that
door for him. If there's a wahmen you- she
best open her own fucking doors. There's
NO WAY you can be polite and open the
doors. LET HER OPEN HER OWN GODDAMN DOOR! But
what if I just want to be polite? That
doesn't matter! Now. Edgar is three years
old, isn't that right Edgar? Edgar: oh yeah.
which basically means he's 13 in dog years.
Edgar: What?! Pewds: yes that is exactly how that works
shut the fuck up. So we're going to watch
a video that helped me as a young 13
year old boy, really shape my way of
looking at wahmen, and respECTING wOmen I
didn't go from this to this in just a
day! Respecting women takes time, patience
skill, motivation. Here we go, here we go.
*yt video plays* dear thirteen-year-old boys yes don't
ask a girl it's her time of the month
Pewds: that's right Edgar! I can have you- you best not
aaaask! Edgar: but I can't speak :( Pewds: good keep it that
way. IDIOOOOOT *video continues playing* dear thirteen year old boys.
don't try and slide into a girl's dms.
Edgar: But what if she is super hot???
I- I don't know actually about that one...
that I mean OF COURSE not what do you-
you got no respect for women! don't-- don't you
dare ever EVER slide in to a girls DMS
because if you do-- that means you don't
respect wahmen. If you ever slide in my
DMS you best be sure-- you have RESPECT
for me. Because if you don't have respect
for me... you don't have respect for
wahmen. *video continues playing* Dear 13 year old boys.
Stop wearing so much Nike sports athletic gear.
Pewds: EDGAR! WHAT ARE YOU DOOING! ARE YOU WEARING NIKE?!
Never wear Nike Sportswear.
That's right. That's right, think about that one yeah
that's right-- yeah you- shame o-, Shame, shame Edgar. (laughs)
whispers: so cute :3
*video continues playing* Dear thirteen-year-old boys. Don't
act like a big huge jerk when a girl says she doesn't want to go out with you.
OOOOOOOOOh!! Did you hear that?! I like her face
when she does that one because it's like--
*impersonating the girl in the video* Dear thirteen year old boys don't act like a
big jerk when a girl doesen't want to go out with you.
*laughs* It's a good finish. It's a good finish.
*video continues playing again* Dear thirteen year old boys. It's okay to have acne. I have acne. A lot of my friends have acne.
That's right! And if you don't have acne, you are disrespecting wahmen and you need
to rethink what you're doing with your
facial construction... liking musical
theater is completely okay that doesn't
make you gay. Wait wait what say what *video continues playing* liking musical theater is completely okay that
doesn't make you gay. (Poods guffaws) Yeaya it does! Musical theater? That's more gay than liking anime and
manga dude. If you like anime and manga...what a fucking nerd. It's super gay dude.
You like theater? What are you...what are you you know like... Musical theater...that's
super gay; isn't that right Edgar?  Edgar: But I
love musical theater. Pewds: SHUT THE FUCK UP
YOU'RE NOT MY SON!
I'm kidding I love you (pewds gives an air kiss) I love you.
*video continues playing* Dear 13 year old boys don't "poof" your hair up
to Jesus. Pewds: What the fuck does that mean? Nehahaha
No, you can't make me choose between
wahmen and Jesus it's Jesus every time.
If I want to "quef" my hair up to Jesus I
can do it and so can you Edgar, listen
here boy
don't listen to this wahman. If you want to "quef" your hair up to Jasus. You best do that.
That's right, I'll "quef" my hair ALL I WANT to Jasus. I'm "queffing" to Jasus right now.
guys...and I'm respecting wahmen. *video continues playing* Dear 13 year old boys it's okay to not
have muscles it's okay to not have abs
it's okay to not love yourself. Pewds: Are you
saying it's okay not to have these BIG
bad boys...are you saying it it's okay
not to have this super (definitely real) abs  and it's okay
not to love yourself? *pewds singing Ave Maria* all right I think
we learned a lot here today about
respecting women isn't that right Edgar?
thank you...thank you Edgar. Respecting
wahmen...it's not a joke okay
and I want you everyone to everyone to
follow my lead and give me your best
respecting wahmen posts right now as you're watching. And also I-- this is
really important to me because it's like
I know this is all a joke with the hair
and all but this is very important to me
It's something I wanted to do for a very
long time I I just never really got the
time to do it properly. I really want to
change the brofist I find it to be
offensive...insensitive and a
microaggression. The brofist is so
heavily male-structured and pandering
to men when we really need to just focus
more on respecting wahmen so I want to
change the brofist to something else
I've given this a lot of thought it's an
iconic moment in this channel history
but we're changing the brofist into
something gender-neutral something that
anyone no matter who you are can get on
board with I want to call it, "The Sis Fist". "Sis Fist". Respect Women Fist. That's it.
Respect wahmen. Respecting wahmen, one punch
at a time. That was a bad joke I'm sorry.
Don't..don't hit women but don't hit guys too. *blaring horn*
There's one more video uh- UGH!- by 3DMOVIES4U- errr a legend absolute legend this
guy taught me everything I know about
wahmen. He taught me how to respect wahmen.
as you can tell he's an old man so he
knows what he's talking about.
That's how it works. *3DMOVIES4U video plays* And when I date a
woman- Pewds: mm-hmm. *video continues* I don't go over and open up
the door for a woman. Pewds: As he should ,see...this man knows you don't open up the
door for wahmen because they need to feel
strong. *video continues* I treat her like crap and they
love it
they respect ya for it. Pewds: Are you telling
me...wahmen...can respect men? No that's impossible!
How could this be?!
I've been fed a lie! All this time.
3DMOVIES4U, what else knowledge do
you have for us?  *video continues* You know I've been
through the opening the car door and
saying I love you honey- is there anything I can do
for you honey yes honey you're right
honey that's bullshit *laughs* Pewds: WHAT?! *video continues* Treat her like
dirt! Pewds: Whoa! *video continues* Argue with her tell her she's
dumb. Pewds: Ugh, what? *video continues* You know treat her like crap
they love it! Pewds: *laughs*
treat her like they love it I love this...
I love this man. The fuck is this...just punch your lady they love it. *video continues* Rharharha women want tough guys-
they don't want little fairy wimps that
open the car door for 'em and treat 'em
with respect and pull out the chair at the
restaurant. They wanna...they they want to be
treated like a buddy. Pewds: I need to write that down. *video continues* They can sit  the restaurant themselves...they
don't need you to pull out their chair for 'em. Pewds: Does anyone have a paper?! *video continues* They want to be a buddy! I need
to fuck my buddy okay I got it. *video continues* Hey tough guy so treat him like crap; give 'em what they
want baby...rharharah...don't you get it? Pewds:
I guess not. *video continues* Look I've been around the
block a few times. I've had, I don't know...Pewds: Probably
6,000 vaginas. 48 women in my life. Pewds: 48?! 48 nig...shit...nig...I said nig... 48?! 18?!
18?! 48?! This man is living sex machine.
48 women eh? You know I... I I might have
done this wahmen thing wrong.
maybe this 3DMOVIES4U man is
right after all. *video continues* I've never had a 10 but
I have lots of 9s...lot of 'em. Lot's of 'em.
Pewds: With a mustache like that BOI how come you
never had a 10? I don't get it. I don't
get it at all man. Dude you fucking tight as shit
man, you deserve a 9 (means 10). *video continues* And other women that you marry if
you marry a really good-looking sexy
woman she might cheat on you. Pewds: MARZIA! Maaah!
I think we learned a lot about
respecting wahmen here today boys and and
AND GIRLS AND GIRLS especially
especially girls...is this video... Do I
have any girls watching this video? If
you are then let me tell you; Edgar, you
you finish this video you say something good. Let me put on some nice music... *Clannad After Story Opening plays*
Hi, my name is Fehlix this is my dog
Edgar. We respect wahmen. Do you respect
wahmen... as well? Then please leave a like in this video that would really... Every like
equals one respect of the wahmen. And if this video doesn't get 10,000 likes, Edgar will
never appear on this channel again-
because I will export him to a third
world country where he will learn how to respect wahmen properly. Thank you all for
respecting wahmen...and as always "Sis Fist".
Have fun! Come on tough guy (Ha!)  Hmmm...okay not
bad. You think you can take me out huh?! (Inaudible) (Poods) See ya guys. Mission failed, we'll get 'em next time.